alors nous travaillons avec les
associations de défense des
consommateurs je les ai d'ailleurs réuni
vendredi dernier nous avons passé deux
heures ensemble justement pour leur
demander de jouer ce rôle de vigie ce
rôle d' alerte pour défendre les
consommateurs
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation nous
avons plusieurs circuits de distribution
des circuits de distribution qui sont
portées par l'état je veux d'abord
rassurer les français
lorsqu ils enverront leurs enfants à
l'école il y aura des masques
disponibles dans le primaire ne sont pas
obligatoires mais ils seront disponibles
pour leurs enfants
il y aura des masques disponibles au
collège et là ils seront obligatoires
donc les parents jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire n'auront pas à équiper
leurs enfants de masques
deuxième chose importante pour 5 pour
les personnes vers un exploit pour nous
ces masques dans les galeries moi je
suis en train d'aller à l'école et que
je suis en train d'acheminer dans les
écoles et les collèges des volumes de
masques textile et de masques à usage
unique parce que probablement qu'au
début les masques à usage unique seront
plus simple entaille pédiatrique
donc c'est un point que nous prenons en
charge deuxième élément nous mettons à
disposition des préfets et des mères
chaque semaine 5 millions de masques
pour les personnes vulnérables 5
millions de masques lavables 20 fois
c'est 100 millions d'équivalents usage
si vous comparez ça des masques
chirurgicaux par exemple douce est
considérable cela également sera gratuit
troisième chose
effectivement nous avons travaillé main
dans la main avec la grande distribution
pour qu'il prévoit d'acheter des masques
et de les mettre à disposition des
français le plus vite possible ce sera
d'abord des masques à usage unique car
ce que une sont fabriqués de longue date
donc plus facile à approvisionner par
rapport aux délais de réouverture des
commerces puis des masques textile et
pour les masques textile
nous avons travaillé sur un prix de 2 à
3 euros 2 à 3 euros pour des masques
lavable de 5 à 30 fois ça fait un prix l
usage qui nous est indiqué par la grande
distribution de 10 à 30 centimes lusage
ça c'est également important est ce que
vous prévoyez un accompagnement vous
avez il a été annoncé un accompagnement
pour les collectivités mais peut-être
aussi un accompagnement pour les
personnes les plus modestes pour même de
2,3 euros représente un coût c'est ce
que j'ai indiqué c'est les 5 millions
masque chaque semaine pour les personnes
les plus vulnérables 5000 mémorable
vulnérables sens financièrement d'accord
plus effectivement ça c'est la santé qui
établira la liste des pathologies où les
conditions d'accès à ces masques les
personnes vulnérables aux recettes
faciles d'un point de vue sanitaire
auront accès à des masques enfin massy
avec le conseil qui va bien lorsqu'elles
présentent des pathologies qui les
expose au regard du coc vide et donc là
aussi ce seront des masses qui seront
mis à leur disposition
donc vous voyez on a anticipé ces
situations les personnes nommées à
budget modeste les personnes qui
envoient leurs enfants à l'école et bien
sûr je le rappelle les employeurs qui
n'ont pas la capacité à assurer en
permanence la distanciation sociales
dans leurs entreprises doivent équiper
leurs salariés est ce que vous le dites
aujourd'hui l objectif avec ce
déconfinement et hier le premier
ministre a parlé d' éviter l'écroulement
de la france c'est avant tout une
reprise économique aujourd'hui l'enjeu
que nous avons c'est de refaire démarrer
la machine avec des conditions
sanitaires irréprochable ces conditions
sanitaires il faut les respecter
strictement rien ne serait pire que de
ne pas respecter la distanciation
sociale et de devoir constater une
reprise du virus et de devoir tout
arrêter à nouveau et on est capable de
le faire dans les entreprises où le sait
il ya des entreprises françaises qui
exercent notamment en chine et qui nous
font des retours sur le fait qu'elles
n'ont pas eu de cas pas eu de cas de
coronavirus dans leur équipe et on parle
d' équipe de plusieurs milliers de
personnes depuis leur reprise
donc ça c'est un récit intéressant mais
ça veut dire aussi de notre part
collective
de la discipline le déconfinement ce
n'est pas le retour à la vie convivial
qu'on a connu malheureusement vous
souhaiterez tous mais ça ne sera pas
possible dans l'immédiat